getting your money in order can feel a
little overwhelming
that's why Dave created the baby steps
they break it down for you and show you
exactly what to do next baby step two is
where you get rid of all of your debts
one at a time using the debt snowball in
the debt snowball you list your debts
smallest to largest by amount owed pay
minimum payments on all of the debts
except for the smallest one and attack
it with a vengeance I mean go ninja
crazy on it once it's gone take the
money you were putting towards that
debts plus any extra money you can find
and attack the next debt on the list
once it's gone take that combined
payment and go on to the next step knock
them out one by one the point of the
debt snowball is behavior modification
when you ditch the small debt first you
see progress that will get you fired up
soon the second debt will follow and
then the next when you see that the plan
is working you'll stick to it by
sticking to it you'll eventually succeed
and becoming debt free
you